A new hostel built inside a jumbo jet plane has now opened in Sweden's capital.
And for those romantics who like flying high, a honeymoon suite is available in the jet's cockpit.
The new jumbo jet hostel at Stockholm's Arlanda Airport offers flyers a whole new departure.
Opening this week, the decommissioned Boeing 747...
...has been completely refurbished to accommodate travelers,...
...but this time under different circumstances.
The 450 seats have been stripped out,...
...and instead, there are now 25 bedrooms and nine bathrooms.
Like any other self-respecting establishment, the Jumbo Hostel also boasts a honeymoon suite,...
...sited in the cockpit naturally, and the only room on the plane with en suite bathroom facilities.
And the wedding theme doesn't stop there.
So, we're going to have their "wing walk,"...
...and at the end of the wing walk, you can get married.
Sited within walking distance of the airport terminals,...
...where up to 18 million passengers pass through every year,...
...the hostel's owner, Oscar Dios, is confident the enterprise will take off,...
...now that the biggest challenge has been overcome.
The most challenging with this project was trying to build something inside a metal hull;...
...it's just really, really tight.
It's very different from building a house.
The construction issues resolved,...
...the sky's the limit for Dios,...
...who says he wants to build a fleet of jumbo jet hostels around the world.